[Music]
my name is Daniel Langer I'm a product
manager at data dawg
I'm joined by Michael McClintock who's a
senior systems administrator at Marketo
she's to give a brief overview what
we're going to talk about today just so
everyone knows gonna talk a little bit
about monitoring how we think about
monitoring a data dog some best
practices what monitoring is all about
if you haven't really dug into dug into
it before talk a little bit about the
change from on-prem to these dynamic
cloud environments and how monitoring
has changed throughout and then I'll
pass it over to Michael and he'll dive
deeper into Marketo story their
migration from on from to Google and how
they monitored along the way using data
dog and we'll leave plenty of time at
the end for any questions you may have
so this is a three you know a three
party migration story it involves
Marketo the other ones who actually
migrated but Google Cloud was very
involved along the way as you'll hear
later from Michael and data dog played a
part in aiding that as well
so for those of you who don't know what
data dog is we are a SAS based
monitoring solution we collect
information from your infrastructure
from your application from logs we
create awesome time series dashboards
and alerts so that you can get notified
when things are going wrong and get to
the bottom of issues immediately we have
over 250 s vendor supported integrations
with all the popular services that you
might be using to power your
infrastructure also we're hiring and if
you want to learn more about open
Rosalia feel free to chat with me after
so not too long ago I was I was in Japan
and as anyone does in Japan they go get
sushi and I went to a pretty unique
sushi restaurant and in the style of a
conveyor belt how it works is you take
your seat and there's this big rotating
conveyor belt where sushi chefs are
preparing sushi and placing it on the
conveyor belt and eventually it comes
around to the table in front of you and
you could pick it up in any
you could also order specialty items and
the chefs will make it and it'll come
around and make a little sound when it's
your item and you can pick it up and
because I live and breathe and eat
monitoring I started to think how would
you monitor this type of operation and
it got me thinking and it made me
realize that this type of restaurant
isn't too far off from you know a
website right I or a web server where
you know you're making requests for
sushi and you get sushi back and made me
think wow this is really in parallel to
how we think about monitoring and data
at data dog so how do we think about
monitoring well we break it into three
three unique parts we have what's called
work metrics and these are the set of
metrics that are directly impacting your
end users there are things like
throughput successes errors how long
things are taking so we think about the
sushi the sushi example throughput might
be how quickly sushi is entering the
conveyor belt right what's the number of
sushi pieces entering that conveyor belt
it you know per second what are the
number of correctly made sushi pieces
versus incorrectly made and finally how
long does it take for customers to get
that piece of sushi when they after they
ordered it right what's that latency
again these are those set of metrics
that are directly impacting your user
experience and ones that your user
immediately notices under the hood
though there's a set of resource metrics
and these are the things that are
powering powering your system under the
hood so they're things like utilization
saturation errors and availability and
to put this in to context
utilization might be how busy are the
chef's and how big is their backlog of
items that they have to that they have
to prepare how many pieces of the raw
ingredients do they have are they out of
tuna are they out of rice how much do
they have to work with customers might
not notice these immediately right
they're not customer impacting metrics
but they very well might be the root
cause of issues and finally there's
events these are context rich sources of
information that occur at a point in
time so you know I have those examples a
code change
you might be configuring something
differently and push a change you might
spin up new infrastructure any of these
things are our events that might have an
impact on your operations right so chef
quitting a knife breaking a machine
breaking any of these things could
impact your operations so we put it into
the example of you know a a a modern
system that you might be you might
recognize we can look at RabbitMQ which
is a popular open-source messaging
system for sending messages across
systems right
those work metrics are gonna be the ones
that you or you know your developers or
that your end-users might actually
notice how big is the queue of messages
that are lining up how many
unacknowledged messages are there things
along that nature under the hood though
there's something powering these queues
right there CPU there's memory
there's network you know there's there's
compute resources that are actually
powering this this disk you system and
then finally there's events that might
occur right you might push code changes
you might update configuration all these
things could affect the the performance
of these of these queues so great we're
collecting these different types of
metrics we are looking at events where
we're centralizing it into one place but
we want them get notified when things go
wrong right we don't want to notice
things on a dashboard hours later we
want to get notified the moment
something arises so that we can take
action so how should we think about
alerting and notification so the way we
think about it is we want to page or get
notified on those work metrics the
metrics that our customers are directly
that directly affect the customer right
the latency right the sushi is taking
longer to get to customers let's go
let's get alerted on that the number of
incorrect pieces that our customers are
receiving is doubled let's let's get
alerted on that once you receive those
you can then dig into those those
resource metrics behind the hood those
those ones that are powering the system
and figure out what's going on and then
you could also take a look at the events
that have occurred in that time frame
right maybe an event caused a change
that impacted your bottom line and
affected your customers directly and the
reason we think about allure
on those work metrics the ones that
directly impact the customer and not
necessarily the resource metrics is the
resource metrics don't always tell you
the full story so if we you know we
think about our sushi example getting
notified that the amount of tuna we have
in stock might be useful at 5 p.m.
before the dinner rush but at midnight
or 3 a.m. you just got paged for
something that might be unnecessary and
interrupt your sleep so we like to think
about those customer facing metrics so
let's talk about alerting as in the
context of on-premise data centers the
these these data centers are more static
right you have a set of servers in a in
a data center somewhere that you've
allocated for your for your application
and when it comes to alerting on those
servers it's a very host centric I'd
ideology
you know you might write these checks or
these notifications when a server is
having a problem so in this example we
have four servers running and we have
four alerts right that notify us when
when one of each of these servers is
going down you know at a scale of four
everything might be okay you've written
the checks everything's okay but then
what happens if you want us you want to
spin up a new server right you you've
you've outgrown your datacenter and
you've architected a new one well then
you have to you have to add a new alert
for this for this server so let's do
that
but wait actually we realize we need to
we need to spit up one more server we
need to you know add one more server to
our to our data center
okay so let's edit an alert to that and
as you can see as you continue growing
this host centered model becomes an
extremely manual process because you
have to continue adding these host
centric alerts to to them in order to
get full coverage and what's more is you
only have that really host centric
information you might get notified that
a host is down or a host is having
problems or a server is having problems
but then what you know that's only a
small sliver of the story you have these
who might have an entire hour you know
environment with databases and web
servers and
who knows what we're only getting
notified when the server is is having
issues but things are changing we're
moving into dynamic infrastructures
where you're writing micro services
across across you know regions and
availability zones and using containers
that spin up and down and disappear and
you don't always know what's running at
one time so how do you monitor something
like this where it isn't static and it's
ever-changing
the answer is tags so tags are key value
pairs that provide context and
information about all the different
pieces in your infrastructure so if we
look at the Google console right here we
have a few machines running and we'll
notice a few sets of important
information that we consider tags so we
see a zone we see a machine-type we see
a network and we see those labels that
are applied to each machine all of these
are context rich tags that give us
information about the the infrastructure
itself and what it lets us do is create
data points right so we can collect
metrics from all these various sources
so we can have a metric that might be
something like a bytes received we can
have a value how many bytes we actually
received when did it happen and then we
can add the where did it come from right
it came from a certain zone it came from
a certain machine type a hostname
certain role a team an environment and
then you can have context around these
data points so that you can do things
like this I want you to imagine each one
of these cubes has a some data point in
it right a number that could be the
number of errors on each cube is a set
of tags that describe that describe that
cube right it could be it's a
combination of a machine-type zone and a
role and these are all machines that
might be bundled up and what you can do
is start to group splice and dice and
filter this data in a way that's
important to you based on these tags so
for instance if we wanted to get those
three purple cubes across the middle
we'd say okay show me all of the you
know show me all the data for
u.s. East one a for an machine-type Heim
m2 and it can return you all the metrics
for that exact criteria of data and what
does this let you do and one it lets you
move from a host centric model of a
learning to service centric model of a
learning and I want you to imagine the
scenario where you have a group of you
know Google compute engine that all have
some common tag right say it zone these
are all in a similar zone and right now
we have one alert that's monitoring all
of the machines in this one zone so if
you spin up a new group of instance this
say you auto scale-up you need more
capacity and those machines are in the
same zone well your alert already covers
that right it's looking for that zone
tag and saying I'm alerting on all
things in that zone if new host gets
spun up with that same zone I can
automatically alert on them you don't
need to manually add any any new alerts
there's nothing to configure alerting
just works and if we go back to our our
small example of RabbitMQ and we look at
it quickly and data dog this is an
example of creating that type of alert
and data DOM and what we're looking at
is the number of messages coming from
each one of our queues and it's only
looking in one particular zone that US
central zone so we have four queues
there right it's split up by name and if
any of the number of messages in any of
these queues reaches 10 we get alerted
so if we create a new queue in zone US
central 1b it'll automatically get
applied to this alert group and you can
get notified and take action right away
so that's a brief foray into monitoring
what we think about monitoring how we
approach monitoring and how monitoring
is changing as infrastructure is
changing I'm not gonna pass it off to
Michael who's going to talk more about
Marketo and their migration journey
thank you can you all hear me yep great
so I'm Michael I am a Senior Systems
Administrator with Marketo I'm working
out of our Dublin office in Amir hence
the funny accent I work with Mike Adam
we are a customer engagement platform so
what that what we do is we do marketing
automation and I'm not a Salesman so if
you want to know more about customer
engagement and how Marketo can help you
improve the way you engage with your
customers we have a stand right over
there so you've no excuse not to go on
your way out of this talk what's really
important on this slide that you should
have a look at is that we grew by 30%
with our revenue in 2017 and so that
caused us some scaling issues right and
so we encountered the on-premise issues
that you will have heard it talks right
across this conference this week and so
we made a decision to move to partner
with GCP and to move our infrastructure
to Google so the sort of issues we were
having that we were looking to fix with
the move to gcp were scalability issues
and flexibility issues but we were also
having some issues of monitoring so
while we investigated and embarked on a
journey to move to GCP we also decided
to change the way that we monitor our
applications so the sort of issues that
we're having on the monitoring side is
that we had multiple tools to monitor
the same thing so we had different
messages we had different thresholds
with different teams who were seeing
different noise from different
monitoring tools and that didn't work
for us yeah and so what we decided to do
was try and group everyone together and
start using data Doug
so what we began with in our in our
monitoring or in our gtp move is that we
had to make a decision on how to move
our infrastructure to gtp and so we had
this sort of discussion that I'm sure
everyone will have considered which is
that we either would take a lift and
shift approach which was to make our
infrastructure within GCP work for our
application or we take a
transformational approach and make our
application work within GCP and there's
loads and loads of upsides and downsides
to this right there is no silver bullet
there's no objectively correct answer
and what we decided to do is we would
lift and shift our application as the
first phase of our of our migration and
so we embarked on phase one which is now
been completed as part of a three phase
migration to GCP so next year when you
come back we can talk a bit more about
the other two phases and as part of that
we also got to work really closely with
DCP so we we partnered with Google and
we got to work with their CRE team which
has been fantastic
and we got to get Google staff on site
to tell us a little bit of best
practices of running applications in the
cloud if you want to know more about the
CRE transition story that we we did
tomorrow in the fifth nine languages
just downstairs on level 2 and where
we're gonna have a talk from Cindy Kim
just about that so why did we go with
data Doug well and as we started moving
away from our own infrastructure it made
sense for us to take our monitoring out
of our infrastructure as well and so a
SAS based solution worked for us we also
were able to take advantage of those
pre-existing integrations within data
Doug and so we were able to get rich
deep metrics about TCP from day one
without needing our engineers to go in
and create those metrics and start
working out ways to record that and also
we really really liked the custom check
writing within data Doug
so the agent itself is Python based and
checks can be written pretty pretty
simply and because you have access to
all of the checks that they provided you
get some really good best practice in
the code that's shipping and that you're
deploying to your service already and so
what we decided to do when we push it is
we use puppet to push it across our
infrastructure you could push data
target the agent itself you could push
it within a day I don't know if you
should write but you could you could do
it because all you really have to do is
push the agent and start the service and
as long as you've got the API key there
you'll see your metrics straight away
and that was really really useful for us
it was able to give us a situation where
we could do a proof of concept with data
dog really really quickly and then what
we did was some I'll talk a little bit
about how we do this later but we
configured our Google Cloud
integration within daily log which
allowed us to start getting information
about resources that we were using
within GCP and then we started the
arduous journey of converting our
existing monitoring solution and moving
our infrastructure our monitoring into
data log which involved moving over a
thousand IGS checks and if you've
questions I had to go through that
absolutely come up at the end and we can
talk about it because it's it's fun um
we introduced Google spanner as well and
this is a really good example of where
the Google integration and helped us
from straight away so Google spanner
Google spanner was something that we
started using and thanks the data we
were able to get deep metrics of how
spanner works and and what we were doing
in our usage of spanner straightaway so
even though we were lifting and shifting
all of our applications on any part of
our infrastructure of our application
where we decided to do some
transformations we were able to use data
dog straight away and not have to worry
about these changes have reiterated our
application so here's an example of or
just just that we could just talk
quickly about how you would monitor a
migration with data dog so thanks to
what Daniel was talking about with
tagging we were able to effectively
monitor our old infrastructure and our
new infrastructure side by side and
quickly group by that you know whether a
server is in gcp for example or what
version of code we're running or you
know which which I guess zones and
geographical information as well and
what that meant was that pretty much
from day one if you're taking a lift and
shift approach you're able to see how
the performance of your application
within gzp matches with your your
performance on purim and that's really
useful information because you can find
out if you're doing something wrong
pretty quickly
and you can also find out if it's way
better than you were expecting and
there's an example of a dashboard so
you're also able to provide to your
engineers pretty much very simply a
side-by-side view of your applications
performance any code changes they push
they can see that straightaway it's real
easy to design so even I can do it
so other changes that we implemented or
other initiatives that we took as part
of this move we decided we go down and
infrastructure as code route which meant
that we started using Peres form to
control our rtcp environment but we
didn't want to stop there we wanted to
try and use this philosophy or this
approach everywhere that we could so
there is actually a terraform provider
available for data Doug and what that
means is that you can control your data
the instance with terraform which is
great because one of the big concerns
that we have and certainly if you're
considering data and concern you might
have is that if you have a SAS solution
which is fully managed through a web
client you're worried about who can
access it who can change it what happens
if you lose your your configuration what
happens if you click the wrong thing and
if you manage this with terraform you've
got some really good options so for
example you could just lock down the
entire web client to make it impossible
to manage the the instance through the
web client to make all changes go
through terraform and what that then
allows you to do is you can put all of
your changes to your data log
environment through code review it
effectively apps acts as a as a DRS
system as well if you if you lose your
head or instance you can rebuild it
pretty quickly and it allows you to
rollback any bad monitors you introduce
any anything that's too noisy or
anything that that isn't working
and as part of this change we also
changed the way that we handle incident
response so this is an ongoing move that
we're making so the I mean you could
have the best monitoring system in the
world but it's kind of useless if it's
not paging you or if it's paging you in
the wrong way and so we started working
with page duty as well as part of this
move and that allowed us to have a
rules-based really deep powerful pager
routing system and it allowed us to
populate and pass our data dogtags all
the way to our on-call engineer so as
Daniel was pointing out the tags were
one of the most valuable bits of
information that we were able to add
into our observability so we were able
to
take a tag from our from our servers so
for example a version of code that it's
running the role that the server is
playing within the application and when
we page an on-call engineer or we wake
somebody up we have that information
right there and it's available to
everyone and so this allowed us to
really improve the way that we were
conveying information to our engineers
who are on call and on calls not an easy
thing to do so or it's not a nice place
to be so it's always nice to make it as
easy as possible and so just as an
example of the sort of ease of use and
quality of life improvements that you
get out of using data log as part of
this the data odd claret integration is
really really or that google claret
intubation it's really simple to
configure you can do it in minutes I
would say so all you all you really need
to do is you create a service account
within GCP and you just make sure that
you're giving it the correct permissions
I think we have a slide here it's hard
to read but as long as you've got
monitoring viewer permissions within
that service account that account can
pretty much start giving you information
into your data audiences straightaway on
day one so you just take a JSON based
private key and then you go into your
data dog instance and you just put that
key in place and you will start getting
information straight away and that comes
with pre-built dashboards so you don't
have you can within 15-20 minutes of
starting to used a login DCP you can
start seeing all of your resources all
of your usage all of everything you need
on a dashboard straightaway and this is
this is an example of the the
integrations that you get or they within
data dogs so these are the GCP
integrations that they provide
dashboards and monitoring for
out-of-the-box but what's really useful
is that it doesn't stop here so tender
send is 250 plus integrations which
means any application if you're using an
application that's widely used almost
certainly there's some foreign bit of
integration there and if it's not there
it's probably on its way and if you
don't see it it's free quite simple to
do put that in place yourself
[Music]